thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
tonight
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
games and around man let's get this
going let's play some Halo infinite I
don't know what else we gonna play all
right you know I'm we're open to
suggestions
but right now Halo infinite is what we
start
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
delicious
um so far uh it's not that there's no
audio
all right well what's going on is we're
waiting for some people to show up I I
can let you guys listen to the to the to
the Halo soundtrack that's fine but as
far as us you ain't be hearing us right
now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
So So currently slo-mo uh you can't hear
me you can't hear us uh you can hear the
Halo theme song until we get everyone
all in together and then momentarily
you'll be hearing us thank you have a
nice day
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
you can definitely cut come in here and
play with us too
[Music]
thank you
Nation Harris how do I play some games
with the Lords once we get some once we
get the people in here uh that that you
know some influencers I'm gonna try to
get smooth in here because everyone
loves inflate raging once we get people
in here and then we'll start sending
invites to the people in the chat but
you'll have to send me a message on Xbox
Live so I know what profile it is and I
will invite those people to the game I
don't know if we're gonna mess it a
whole lot with parties today we might
just depending on what goes on
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
like I had to put people onto Lloyd
Banks ain't no click
uh I promise the guns I get
all right that that's cool
straight up on that kryptonite I be on
it on it
oh my God
I be on that infinite straight up all
that infinite I be on it to be mad at us
imagine how fun he's gonna get with Ford
[Music]
these dudes is dead wrong
and it happens all the time
what happened
all right so they what
no custom game look at it cause it's in
the custom game
you guys gonna have to all right all
right relax guys relax I I'm not ready
relax
ing the messages blowing up
can I make more than two teams you used
to be able to do this in Halo but you
know this is Halo infinite sometimes
it's hit and miss
all right let me start sending some of
these people invites to the party
Lucius uh sure you can come on in
I can't come in yet pause
calvinston all right come on in
[Music]
my boy Galveston
this is straight BS they just hit me
with a 40 gig update
oh no why is with you always having
these updates
is a whole different car so audit
this happened last time he was like
well I didn't have it downloaded the
last time stop telling everybody what is
wrong with you you've been playing
PlayStation today snitching
how do y'all not invite the uh the Halo
Super Saiyan well you gotta ask who's
that I can't uh 108 drivers who's that
laughs
get over here
yo it's just Wolf Creek because on my
side it just says it's in the custom
game and it's just like oh you want to
see symbol
for unlimited
you see me in the um Lobby or something
do you see me yeah we're good
shoot up
you see me in the club
uh technical lamb um I'm gonna try to
keep the people in the chat the people
playing the game so we don't get there
you go who's talking fish
there you go look at this
surprise surprise
I don't uh I don't think I have you on
Xbox
I'm in the party but I'm not in the game
oh that's fine oh here you go
that was lucious who was talking by the
way okay cool I sent it to the hospital
Saturday
uh send me a message
uh here's my oh dip down Jeopardy yeah
everybody there is my stuff uh my
government name unfortunately is up
there but it's okay you guys pretty much
know my name at this point uh so the
business is my gamer tag the Cog how do
you go to what you call it and take off
this stuff that you have in suspension
stuff oh you gotta go oh send me a
message
the Xbox Live baton
to buy games and apps yeah to see all
send it all
right go to it should be underneath like
man it's just it's just EQ something and
all the stuff is in queue or update guys
yeah and then you gotta press the start
button over the one you got that the one
that you want to force the Halo or
whatever you want to press start over
that what's that one be like yo you go
first
no no not that I'm talking about this
stuff that you have in
um uh what's the quick play
oh Quakers on the quick resume you know
how you can go in there you can just
yeah go off to free up um because right
now yo your system be working
and you want it to be free
that maybe it could operate fine pick
what's wrong
it speeds up everything
I never had no issue with the download
but yeah for me I got the um
when I go to the my gaming apps I got
them in different groups so I got like a
group oh I know
yeah it'll say quick results for me
there's a quick resume download
something
yeah I'm trying to do it super fast so
when yeah quick resume
no so you go to my games and apps and
then you go to where you're downloading
it where in your queue and then it'll
say how fast you're downloading it and
then you say suspend the game because
it'll tell you hey this thing can go
faster if you suspend your game yeah in
that queue
that's where you have to go
all right you got you got you guys can't
just add me like you need to send me a
message like I've had like five oh hold
on mess up my uh friends request I need
a message
um
can I cover invite to your game please
yes
that is very Posh
very official thank you it's very harsh
there I'm British I can't help it no no
that's British family I respect
different kind of British to this
British
oh look at this one I'm a Midland
gibberish
who let these midweek dudes in here
they all mixed up we almost had always
messed up attic
yes
what the what screen am I supposed to
see right now just a custom game or
something or I just see a flash of you
at that c symbol yeah
sometimes custom games is a little
messed up
and stay quiet
[Laughter]
I was like this don't look like it's
supposed to be happening
it looked there but it's not as big as a
king's 40 gig update like two gig
you send me
a message on Xbox Live and I will get
you in here we're gonna have to rotate
people out
uh you know because I want to do more
than just big Team battles so we will
rotate battle but I do want to have more
than just victims
he's so used to not playing with people
he don't talk
he forgot to use his mic
actually
sir
see you open it yo yo y'all hear me get
down yeah
we'll play the beta game I'm expecting
big things from you Cog with your
destiny experience easy
[Laughter]
right now put it on the big team
neither of us
player is foreign
I don't know
we'll see we'll see what happens I start
Ed
loading screen animation
yeah
it's a new splash screen
to solve her with nobody
who's that he spent money
in a play hey
pay the look I like it
oh they out here they out here yeah they
are yeah oh [ __ ] your name
what the hell
yeah straight up
one on the SpongeBob oh someone got a
rocket launcher in the middle yeah yeah
get him
yeah oh yeah oh
everybody out here dirty with it yeah
hit me
there he was
80. oh
okay man I'm getting teamed up on two
three years
to say
something I'm watching somebody could be
the first one could be the first one
nope
I wanted you I'm not gonna get double
teamed I'm going back to you guys
you out here running outside they out
here playing all sweaty attacked
it's like that oh yeah yeah
man the guy was behind me with a shouty
you got excuses sorry ain't talking so
that's that's messing up the team
opposition
that's what I hope I've already gone for
yo how I just spawn and I'm getting shot
they're throwing their names
go
why you are you ready why are you
hopping why are you running why are you
running okay left why are you ready over
show the middle
oh they're coming high in the middle
man I can't get any kills I'm getting
all these assists unfortunate
what assist do we have three kills
no yeah yeah
it's my first one
his first game first game
the problem is y'all are walking these
streets
hold on let me punch you in my mouth I'm
still trying to move
yeah Galveston don't be hopping and run
it down
enemy behind us
that sound protect
nice
if the speaker
shotgun man
the jump is left bumper run him down
this is embarrassing
[Laughter]
foreign
looking at my stream to find out where
we are so they can kill me effectively
yeah oh
that's an idea that is
okay
thank you
what is she using man
it's all right
I emptied a full clip into him and he
shot me one time I was dead I probably
had a shotgun or something
all right
there you go
but you download it now sir
no no I had to make sure my junk was
downloading that uh
yeah
my joint was downloading at 200 and I'm
like that's not what I paid for I pay
for that yeah I was like no no we got to
reset you sir you you need me so he got
reset it that wasn't enough no that's
not the team it's not the previous
let me down
yeah I got a truck but I ain't gonna get
no kids
that's the first streak I went on too
the 2020. we got the 2020 in it
oh they playing the sad music your door
is a rat when they play the sad music
just means the game's about there
thank you
yes that's what I'm talking about
here we go how people gonna tell Dutch
uh you shouldn't take time off to
mentally be charged the hell
yeah
my man was trying to you know get his
break gonna take a break he's supposed
to take breaks because contact created
sir
you would hope so
yeah right
well it gave me the cheap bit for
playing custom
oh man
wow
okay sending out the messages
all right send those messages out if I
come joining you soon in a couple of
seconds Jeremy though yes I got you I am
Jeff
yeah I had to restart Halo I didn't make
it that first wave invites
what's up you said that one-on-one did
back in again
why are you trying to do one-on-one
say that boy oh boy lemon's here
yeah man you know how he did he got a
little bit of smoke in fortnite just
left never seen the man again oh damn
it
went and had a turkey sandwich and just
never came back
[Laughter]
somebody said that Halo is dead
nah fall
yes
the tales of my exploration has been
largely exaggerated to let me see
something beside a little splashy screen
come on now wow [ __ ] you
I'm sorry
[ __ ] you oh what's up
all right I'm jumping in now at least
I'm loading at this time let's see yeah
I got an infinite UNSC logo it's still
on Arena I know I joined system
thinking the data from the what you did
before press RT
there it is that's you know you playing
with special people and they telling you
all right they're not looking at your
controller yeah um excuse you uh press
the RT button yeah that's ridiculous
Lord Atticus in a custom game
oh yeah maybe I should oh no you
you're in here Quiet Now find your team
the hockey monkeys Lord Cognito all
right give me one more guys one more
if you guys want in like I said remember
you have to click uh you have to hit the
bank can you let me talk don't hit the
cash app
if you want to play
if if you want yeah you have to share a
message on Xbox
with with monetary compensation sir I
mean you guys can always start with the
Super Chat you know we definitely
appreciate that
hit the coffers as you walk patreon
hit the coffins as you walk in the door
wipe your feet and drop the change I'm
looking at some of these names take your
shoes up put your clocks on he loves him
what yes that's my man's right thing
monkey slow yo little known fact I saw
him running around the tower and Halo I
mean all day a little while that's crazy
in Destiny and I said oh snap hot
monkeys love him and you know how you
you've seen something I said I knew this
dude from a past life I clicked on his
name I chased him right I chased them
get your ass over here and I clicked on
his name and I sent him a friend request
and then it popped up and it was like
yes
unless you cut me out of your soul and I
still come back
[Laughter]
I'm pretty sure crazy
me and this dude in California look like
DTS we could walk five dollars
I'm gonna let the bodies hit the floor
[Laughter]
and I'm gonna say hot one
[Laughter]
get it
I was in full sleep mode
excuses get up let me go to Twitter my
man talk about giving free smoke that's
right I'm getting up right now
guess what I do my gamertag
let's get it
is
coming back
[Laughter]
yo it was messed up is he had to put the
971 I mean the 9-1 7-0 because they
would have been like nah nah nah can't
let you rock with that see
it is
a body good
yeah that's the rule is 1V 1v15 yeah
they know you don't know about them days
yeah
it's disgusting with this
I had the little baby
I don't want to be an ego
we fly
how many teams are there Cobra and
another team get over here
so you want me to be cobra
Cobra
it's not safe for that Cobra team yeah
all right
you heard me
we need one more person okay we got room
for one person you could sleep if you
want to Lemon lemonade
[Laughter]
all right we're going we're going live
am I in the game yes
do not unfriend me after this these
games
all right damage media get out let's go
today we've grown men cry
for her
I got kicked in there too I got kicked
out I got kicked out I'm getting crushed
oh
oh
hey what's up that was a quick game yeah
welcome to the wonderful world of Halo
I'm telling you man I don't like I I
I'll be real with you I don't like
playing games all the issues like I just
don't but it annoys me I do I didn't
play with it
yeah or single player like any of the
things in between are just super broken
still
oh there wow y'all should never give
people stuff to talk about in there
addicts fitting to go in ponya you heard
oh she said
I don't see no Lobby yeah I'm in there
they put me in Eagles group
she pressed that right just right the
wind is Green Lemon we got yeah
yeah
so if you're not coming to the building
team you over there listen man like I I
need to get my legs under me again I got
like two kills at that
cap over there okay okay
package on this
[Music]
it's not my fault I said multiple times
shoot us the thing how to go it ain't my
fault
all right
here we go
yeah they should at least let me see the
team composition instead of a UNSC
loading screen
yeah
that's weird yeah
I see everything like I see the go to
multiplayer go to multiplayer and then
you can see the bodies on the ground
foreign
yeah and this is why I'd be annoyed when
people defend this damn thing there
should just be able to jump straight
back in by the way yeah
I'd rather play Tetris in this game at
this point
nothing
oh
okay
next match up here
commentate commentating from the side
yeah yeah you know I only talk crap yeah
oh
man the respawn is so fast
two seconds
you get back in the game yeah
I wake up and as soon as you show up
yo I got the flag hold me down hold me
down somebody got their back open
somebody's right up there running with
it man
you guys it looks like you have backed
up because somebody picked it up right
away good yeah
see you later oh they gotta take deep
they got out they got running keepers
than our team
oh look at that look at that evil even
matchmaking
all right Thanos perfectly balanced I
just stand on Snap like four of them
jump back I haven't tried it yet I had
to see what's going on I tried messing
with two other games in it all no no no
the NFL quarterback game but the death
Loop nah he took my um
addicts a whole demon Prince Commando
starts oh yeah why'd you do this to me
bro how many convenient you put on the
spawn six
do Wildland this is some addicts
playlist
no you don't no you're out of here
you're not running me over get out of it
get out of here
for me I appreciate that see you think I
was opening but I'm actually in your
face mainly in you
this is what y'all do what we deal with
y'all
he knows his behavior is not a
reflection of resource
yes it is
yeah
keep in mind
he's a great figure he's a great sticker
delicious
what's up
look at the difference in the teams here
right now
huh
foreign
benches
look one jumping over the middle the
middle top little top
oh God
they're going for a flag
damn it get him out of there get him out
of there get him off that flag
take it or they out they out they out
oh
look at you get out of here with that
nonsense
lemon has been the only killer right now
on your teeth let me get busy yeah got
it
grenade
but let me let me tell you something
this is a team game
together
man
we come in here deep man we got like
three or four people oh
that's deep [ __ ] that guy
oh [ __ ] you ran up
advocating
don't take it soon as they fight back
your hair sit down deep down
just launching random grenades
creeping like a Ninja Turtles
everybody head towards lemon head
towards including us anymore
when he said that all I heard was they
best shooter got the flag against you
back
[Laughter]
this is that that is the absolute worst
strategy
[Laughter]
I like that
already got the Hammers
how how is that even possible because I
hit you from behind
I don't know man just take the kill and
come down
Sinister take the kill and come back
stronger let's call it
[Music]
towards the flag
this ain't Sunday I ain't got to be
calmed
you're gonna get it
that's right watering dogs
I'm sorry that's tomorrow you come for
the flag you come from
baby strategy baby
all right the real we might be winning
some of these engagements but they gonna
win because they have more they have uh
that that capture
don't let them Rock like that
yes
no go go get that monkey let's go let's
go
where you at
we have to get that on here
attic this one this one got the gun I
got you back that's fine what up
[Laughter]
that's right
it is
the running back ain't that good let's
go
can someone please get a lemon please
[Laughter]
watch your mouth
y'all let him disrespect like that what
to be to be fair that they have another
three people no they not let me do
nothing just let it happen
lemon's been training all week for this
soon
babe
why why have you done this to me Halo
I've been your staunches
Porter
that's when you know you're an abusive
relationship it's easy
it's easy to snatch our flag when you
got three more people
statistically speaking
keep running Jeff
get in the Jeep
yo Jeff good job
[Laughter]
yes
and it didn't work
let's go
for everybody
hey hey don't feel bad man they had
three extra bodies helping them
let's go
they ain't letting us in the club
what the [ __ ] okay and we coming we
coming forward
back up y'all need reinforcements yeah
[Laughter]
you said we gotta go in there with the
purple headbands
[Laughter]
on colors
[Laughter]
we came in with Friday's wristband
what's the last we can have on this
attic probably 28 right now as far as
the games
unless you want to switch to Discord
my coquito brother how you feeling this
morning this afternoon huh
laughs
that's a cool laugh joke
I had the most kills I just couldn't
carry a flag
all right so that are we everyone good
we gotta get an invite put technical
lamb in attention
[Music]
okay so we can take you two but that's
all like after that like we're gonna
have to start [ __ ] man oh okay yeah yeah
they go through yeah
squabble your baby got the squabble
sticks oh you already know how many
people what dudes do yeah like when yeah
basic look right here listen solid
Spartan got a butthole protector look
wow
yes
y'all spending money huh I blew my own
checks
okay
see what you're doing [ __ ] you said nope
they ain't getting no bread until they
fix it
out here picking an All-Star team like
gun yeah like Giannis come on
the way you the way you be talking
living we all can face you and you win
oh let's you're right yeah oh yeah
let's just go crazy
that woke me up man all right I gotta
move on uh it's people that's not
joining like it's oh we're we've maxed
out on people we can have that's what it
is
okay
you can have more in the game you just
can't have more wait a minute party
challenge
I can get you I can get you guys in that
game but the party's full
all right so y'all can get in the game
with the party unless you guys want to
switch the Discord like he said yes my
man lots of spotting four two seven
eight heads
yeah hey crap real real sneaky back
though VIP let's go
real quick stuff
he said yo we'll take you but I'm going
over there
what's the maximum Discord
I mean what's the max in here so I could
make that in the back in the lobby 16.
yeah if you go send this Boom Boom Room
in 16 already well we have to go to
Discord like everyone in the chat yeah
that's a fact
[Laughter]
The Flash
[Music]
since you're going to the middle I know
the biggest weapons in the middle I'm
going to the flag
[Applause]
number one
[Laughter]
let's go
[Laughter]
oh he's coming to the middle oh kill the
job yeah yeah
ask yourself
ask yourself you did it right
yeah
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
I killed everybody full time
see the difference when I get in the
game go
let's go yeah like like that ass up
yo I got teleported what the hell give
me that beat fools
behind you whoa
[ __ ] you police
oh oh
you finally had a one-on-one with me
[Music]
you know
damn well who the hell get away from
that flag get away from that flag
oh there's violence out here oh you
can't walk on that street outside
uh
[Music]
I hate it I hate it I hate it
no fear no fear no fear let's go let's
go let's go oh
going camping I gotta have a vehicle
coming in here
I remember you
foreign
[Laughter]
oh
oh
yeah
we gotta go bro
Dutch I love you yo kick to the flag get
to the flag
oh
don't you ride don't you but I see you
yeah
yeah
get off that I don't like all of them
cars
back up they flagging easy to touch
unless
you put hands on it
oh my God okay
is anybody defending you're awesome
nobody everybody's on this right Hill
for y'all you thought you was coming for
me
this is crazy right [ __ ]
to try to get my flag
Jesus there you go yo let me know
invisible he's invisible
I
think
that's point oh like this Chef dude they
got a point
that's bad you're fighting me I like it
I loved it
I'm upset
we are going yeah we are two going
we'll talk later
nope
[Music]
nope
go
hold on hold on hold on hold on
hold on Don't Make Me Over
oh yo everybody rush Face Forward man
to the flag
[Laughter]
Halo it's fire would it work
nothing like it baby
oh dark
Ness
I'll let them whips man I don't want to
talk to y'all
[Music]
got
me
yeah
we got it yeah
they're they're
controlling the map with these vehicles
flag
yeah oh yo he's above me he's above me
there you go
all right
[Music]
let's go
lay down
let's get out of here That's My Ghost
spaghetti
you can have it keep pushing keep
pushing
you're dead
get that thing right for the tank attack
get that get that tank Lead With
Grenades Lead With Grenades [ __ ]
oh come on
yes
man they got like every heavy weapon
line and we let them get too much stuff
okay so
we'll change it yo what's up in that
tank David get out that tank baby oh oh
no we can't that's too strong
you're talking too strong
that's how you attacking me
distraction
s
[Music]
yeah you're right there on the right on
the right
here yeah I'm pushing I'm helping that's
a damn thing
oh yeah I got tagged by some dude on the
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
out the way
dude how you don't kill me with that
special weapon and stop hiding in the
corner you guys were hiding behind rocks
after that
I'm chasing me bro
I don't care I got your bear okay Okay
and the whole team
together let's talk about it let's talk
about it
[Music]
all right
pistols we put this joint on straight
killing mode
yeah
that's good right now
yeah until I put my hands on you I'm
gonna put my hands
good at that
this black stuff is over best
to drop the knife
they're not
damn it Jim right now
you be acting like you was over there by
yourself there was three of you
you talking about yeah
he's real he's talking real strong on a
room full of people of automatic weapons
dude
there's a dude on the ground
why can't we
two people man two people just pull it
up on me casually
the moment someone spawns on the other
team they're like yeah hold my pocket
the flat get the flag yeah
huh
that's right jump out jump out no you
don't know where I'm at you don't know
where I'm at I could be anywhere
oh
he shot a rocket at me to get me out of
here
come on hello
uh-oh
Let's Go
All right yes
no
he's talking and I will give you guys
what she wants no more people hands only
what you saying
huh he said they were not ready for the
smoke
he said nobody cannot work it
um
that's what we do
that's what we do
we love the community we are Spartans
is it even
oh it's slowed in yeah this is 19. don't
worry
when the bodies start dropping to the
floor it's gonna get even
okay so they have one more than we do
which is fine good they got sovereign
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
whip out
early
yo don't forget y'all can push D up on
your d-pad to mock people man
I'm gonna Mark you right now
all right okay
I do a thing and it hit the tree it
[ __ ] killed myself
all ran to the right it all ran to the
right hand side of the map you lying to
you
she's like let's go
oh yes
why are you hiding in there
get out of here
yeah
the week
y'all better kill me
the mouth
I'll be back
I just cleaned out the cave I'm good
but I'm back go get that truck get that
truck
don't let them get that truck if you
know what they like to do
that
no grenades
you're gonna have to pick up your
grenades buddy
yeah I got them dudes with me
you always rolling with like five are
you Sarah Connor let's go
so every time I do get in a fight three
on one it got the truck y'all let them
get the chance
I took a smacking in the fish oh
let's go
wow
tactical equipment
these Hobbits are out here
look man Hobbits is the reason the Lord
of the Rings is successful don't don't
be don't be letting this man talk what
in the cave hiding one in the cave
wandering Dutch get him let's go
man got the big motorcycle what's good
you got the big wheel let's go
oh yeah
[Music]
I like to be in the fields
he eat a bulletproof truck
I got something
all right what's up
[Music]
don't play by their rules draw them out
in the open and Destroy them
selves
I see what y'all doing
but everybody else
and killing your people
again
there you go
come on
yeah let's go let's go
[Laughter]
this video
let's go
damn yeah
team shoot man get your way
you gotta get around these dudes that
are camping and kill the ones that are
hiding in the back
they jumped
God damn it I lost sound again
little bike a little little motorcycle
Runner I made them lose sound too
um
[Music]
yeah
I don't get in vehicles I destroyed them
take me
I see where they going they're going
inside
stop
[Laughter]
they're going in the pool trying to turn
into Superman bust their cheeks open
all right hey
put put in the chat who should be team
leaders we're going to do some drives we
should be the team leaders two team
leaders
Get Low I need to drive a King Drive me
driving me drive me
he's like I'm not getting out the cage
somebody else
I got y'all got you here
[Laughter]
the spawn swap we gotta go to the other
side all right go go go
only paid situation
oh tentacles
oh God okay okay I see that limiting
King I'm gonna put a poll in the chat if
you see attitude do not shoot addicts
put the poll on the chat
let's go
my team out here
you see the difference when we playing
Kill Em Up Kill Em Up is different than
grabbing a flag foreign
just shoot them out of them
thanks
shoot you man
look at the back of the trees
all right all right all right all right
say something to solve now say something
all right so this is how we're doing
this question all right everyone
everyone
this is how we're doing it all right
everyone go to Observer but King and
lemon you are going to be the leaders
you're going to draft the rest of us
everyone go to all right I'm out I'm out
I'm out I gotta bounce y'all that's fine
he's gonna get me King David OTW hey
leads
I got it okay lamb needs to get inside
the party jet yeah well he can take some
spots
get in here
join on me
how do I get out of here
all right I'm sending invite right now
foreign
okay everybody Observer press right
bumper into your Observer
everybody go observing but lemonade
they're the only two that's not
well well
over the other side right
make sure that you don't have your TV on
loud turn it off how do you do it see
yourself through the mic
and if you got one of those one air
joints you just ass out of luck yeah
oh okay yeah
some dudes be having it man don't don't
don't don't make them feel bad they're
not they're hearing joint and money they
sell them yeah yeah it's called the
broke man special
to the team because I want to make sure
no one accidentally goes to the wrong
thing all right so lemon and King who's
gonna pick first
the winners go first okay no no we got
to pick a number from one to five okay
hold up okay
God man how am I gonna do this all I
know is the only Cog said killer that
tentacles
send me a Facebook message of a number
[Music]
send me a Facebook message of a number
between one to ten and that's going to
be the number
all right
hey and don't do don't do it okay okay
lemon what's the number
six
all right what's the number King
two uh lemon B uh it was seven so
lemon's picking first
oh well you ain't saying I get closer I
thought you would have to pick the damn
number
three let's go let me go first day
I am Jeff I am Jeff
okay who's not uh uh technical okay so
your yard
you got y'all sinister
Sinister okay attic
okay
oh YouTube
okay
um
give attic some time he's switching okay
so he took attic let me see look at this
list Neil
Nia
oh Neo nuke okay I got you
we took somebody Reverb somebody with
the Uno Mike is rebirth Neo went
okay so uh Lucas Lucas okay
[Laughter]
King
yeah yes you don't be scared
okay who did you pick
I picked Lucy
and and I had picked um [ __ ] you
okay honey
[ __ ] you switch over oh no okay yeah he
switched that's why it confused me he
switched outside confused he knows he
knows what he's supposed to okay who did
you pick London
honey
go go over there hoggy
all right you know this this is the part
where this [ __ ] gets nasty sit down
dip down go to King all right I'll take
it I'll take it get down to get down I'm
taking car cause his family don't love
him let's go
[Laughter]
very good all right you know what I'm
saying he did that off though how many
more I mean like crazy that's my guy
who you got
well who's your next pick I picked up I
took monkey
yeah and now it's your turn who's left I
don't know who's left it's uh wandering
Dutch Don gallon Dutch let's go let's go
my guide okay last three
uh you know what I could play this
stupid I could play it snot give me
Galveston
okay lemon who's left it's uh Dawn in
life Supremacy
I'm taking Dawn okay
let's go
all right
who picked first I was really shaking
right there because I really wanted
women yeah
foreign
because you you didn't get a pick first
I just want to kill
him yeah you're on a team no I I did it
I did it manually I did it manually okay
cool same up a different map there we go
hi Tyler it's the new one maybe
it sucks
all right so you guys want Behemoth
Behemoth yeah yeah okay okay
arrested
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
that's it
soil
look at everything you know what I'm
saying I'm gonna kill you yeah oh my God
stop early
early one hit hello
get off that ghost
get off that ghost no vehicles
[Laughter]
you knocked out the big dude in front of
everybody
that's when I pick Incognito first
that's right let's go
oh sugar
it's different
yes I like it
oh man down sucker we put him down
once again hey we'll be [ __ ] up
you're supposed to have a VR too
are they scared of the snipers now
[Laughter]
let's go boom
boom I'ma have like one we got the map
is gonna be spread out of dudes just
laying back in tonight
we supposed to test all the game let's
go
oh
yeah
I'm gonna have you on IOP this Sunday
man
I'm leaving
let's go elbow
[Laughter]
gotta be out here like boss
yo what are you doing you trying to mess
with my boy over here let's go oh look
at y'all look at your camping I love it
I love it and you trying to shoot me in
my back with a sniper
I wish I have a tree
it was real Tactical
ah damn what hopefully next match
show your face from The Horizon
you don't want this work
yo stop running stop running Sinister
I'm coming down
he's like oh my God let me be around for
the Hills
it's here but he's here oh my God
where's that shot coming from
the left he's on the left he's on the
left
um
sorry
I see you guys
is coming from
down by two let's go
what's going on dude I I got your number
you didn't know
mechanical yeah oh
it's bad over there
thank you
I swear to God
I haven't played this game in months
all right look look this is how we're
gonna do it because uh people are
starting to throw a ninja put in there
what you guys think we should play why
are you running up on me y'all yo I'm
just circling them back
what I'm supposed to do
oh Lord oh someone hit me I'm oh man
this is bad
okay
I got you I got you back y'all I got you
let's go let's go
whoever is sniping in his Towers dead
man
thank you
shoot that ghost
I am with with something real nice
told you
Lose Yourself
what's that ghost be like
let's go
people want us to do swords only
two times
hello
whoa
fight he went right to the grenade
God damn lemon
[Laughter]
run run that's right
oh did he like that off the backboard
right
I like that let's go we're down by 10
guys we're down by 10. we can do this
we're down by eight oh twelve
whoa whoa
whoa whoa hey hey prevented the card
[Laughter]
no all of them all I'm killing is iron
Lords
going after your brothers oh
I'm out of bullets
killing y'all yeah
wow I didn't know
are you trying yeah oh who is that oh
you trying to spawn tonight
I'm sorry the spawns on this map like
they put you in like fighting fire like
that
oh man somebody
's tagging me
somebody
hey
when weapons came second place
[Music]
my man out here all right
exchanger everything
no no no no
no
yeah
I'm starting to hurt my own feelings
let's go bro
second time
look at Sinister acting like snipers
look at Sinister act like he's going to
dictate what I do man he changed every
rule in the book look at all these rules
he's mad because the rules change yeah
that's crazy
Sinister that's crazy it's the
difference keep the energy
bro he put the snipers on your ambulance
hurt now look at this he's trying to
trigger me man I won it ain't gonna win
as soon as I started rocking with the
sniper they changed
it keeps glitching it does not rock with
VR at all it refuses to give it to me
rifles
first off I put VR but it glitched why
are we on Dual orders
I put PBR but it glitched
yeah I don't know
it's a glitch games
yeah it's Halo infinite I mean like
that's facts
we might as well be playing a beta like
for real like
that's ridiculous
still hiding in their base
and the whole team is in the base hiding
you guys high high that's fine man don't
let this man bully you into coming out
there and share with foreign
I think
somebody's sniping up in the bushes
invisible bunch of people right eating
this
right behind you
and you saw me
yo you shot him with a shotgun four
times four times in the chest with a
shotgun and nothing happened okay all
right
okay
you needed a truck
two grenades tell me why I just fell off
the map destruction
already
does anybody know what the lottery
yeah yeah
but I can't find them
kill him kill him kill him kill him
right there kill him
kill him
why can't you kill him kill him now
interviews for real in the vehicle and
the vehicles already huh all right well
they dropping I'm gonna tell you right
gotta Hammer somebody
let me get up right quick
you didn't hear him
he wasn't he ain't say that
no yo yo yo yo yo yo
here comes the bow here comes the boat
look at this look at this look at it
[Laughter]
I'm gonna make a grown man cry today
the lead is yours
auxiliary
I just ran by something
flamingos over here
let's go
I wish they just brought back the raid
I'm like
to your right
I don't get huggage to me out of that
joint it's okay
m o
let me help you let me help dancing I'm
so close you keep dipping on me
oh my bad I'm trying to help you yo it's
crazy people people will use what like
Vehicles the whole thing we getting a
vehicle is is a problem
I think they should change it to where
vehicles
in foreign
I'ma tell you right now
yeah another walk
just go to the other side and pick on
them that's all
oh
[ __ ]
I believe
we gotta get something out of the sky
look at this
yeah
now we get them
somebody yeah
[Applause]
what's up
let's go no I'm up here with this girl
shooting you guys before with nails
nobody wants that VR no get your ass off
all right
baby
let's go
he and the Rocks hiding up top real
quick sir thank you
shut up y'all
I'm lucky we ain't got no kill streaks
cause y'all be dead
there's a brew Chopper coming in right
there
hey
oh you think you're gonna go up there
and be safe watch when you land get him
at it oh he missed yeah yeah right here
right here get him get him
there's a
there's a warthog showing up around
where I am Jeff is
dang yeah that boy lemon is all right
get that invisible [ __ ] going oh [ __ ] oh
oh God that was crazy
[Applause]
yo it's about time y'all killed me man I
thought I would say let me hop let me
hop on top he was not a cab he was
definitely
get him
okay
right
that's what I just got it
still had the sticker
damn that bank ain't gonna be happy
silence
silence
oh what happened your vehicle don't work
all right
there yes
yeah Sinister what's up we're free
now we like it
like that
yeah
they quiet now they cry
you know what's funny I just want to
point out when I pick stuff that you
guys Vibe with and it's not an issue
when I pick stuff you guys don't Vibe
with addicts finishes
hey we gotta do one thing the chat wants
us to do one thing all right
no it's not hammer
God damn it
you should communicate what you're
putting up here
they could fight long range but they can
no no no
there was people that saw what I put it
wasn't that it it messed up I mean
it's not gonna change anything nice
you ain't got to defend what you saying
because it ain't like we starting off
with better weapons than them we started
off equal it's not an equal talents yeah
the story oh this is gonna be terrifying
what were the scores like 90 delay sir
all right
okay
or just 20 percent
you're gonna be faster let's put it that
way okay oh you put you put the walk
speed up yes
the gerrymandering the whole Lobby
that's crazy
all right what are we playing swords and
gravity happens
that's the Halo infinite way so it's
hard to tell what's gonna happen
if it is infinite possibilities to what
the hell's gonna happen I'm dead yeah
it didn't give the sword for some reason
see what happens with the German area
he said put it in switch mode
20.
120 yep
disrespectful I think he's gonna go down
to
120.00
there you go not discussing what is it
in the game
to play a mode like that I know that
much it's crazy yeah
get this out of here
that was playing hell on the PS5
unlock mode
again watch it be again with these short
range weapons only okay we're gonna
change this back though you know why you
want a long ways
I can see all my neighbors
all right
you don't mind if I do
like ah you Dutch
I'm going so fast I jumped off that map
how do you jump off the mat that's what
I want to know
wow what king killed me where was he I
didn't even see him you know what I hear
right now
videos
oh battle to the death right there ow
oh God damn it
yo what the hell is that dude oh my God
oh you scared hell of it moving Team
guys he sounded like Mr Bean Magic
can't keep up
this is insane
my energy is
yo hold up I ain't got no more bullets
nope
use your hands
it's supposed to be uh
no problem
wait
there's a decent food with your hands MO
[Laughter]
lemon I'm on your six I don't get I
don't got you but somebody's behind us
oh no
oh I know it's time for the get down get
down no you're stupid
but I'm gonna kill your man in the
middle in the middle I'm gonna kill your
boy
they'll stick together and play as a
squad let's take these dudes right out
let's go how are you gonna stick
together around this way hurry yeah
I'm sorry you're falling off the map
you're an idiot like there's not many
places you can follow off the map
there it is
dude
what yes it does yeah it reached around
on me
swords ain't my forte yeah
something new you want insurance I'm
gonna teach you something look at you
talking all this Matt meet me in the
middle meet me in the middle
[Laughter]
let's go catch me outside
behind us
hit him with the black dude
I've been robbed
behind me behind me behind me there's
another one behind you
oh you got a sandwich like a stripper
big
boxing that pole bing bong
[Music]
don't let him get away oh come on
foreign
I love how they're getting in vehicles
[Laughter]
good job y'all
okay
behind y'all
Assassin's Creed
I don't get it oh my God
hey we catching up we catching up like
there's one in groups and just stab
ilities
hahaha
if you see somebody red stuff
oh my God like we got like two parries
back to back that was dope
[ __ ] nice
don't come for me
like that I got the ghost
yeah this sword thing's pretty good
okay
[Laughter]
swing them you'll hit someone
I don't ride hello
choking
[Music]
keep
me
stabbing yeah
one more one more one more
one
more
just cut one let's go
two more seconds
done done
on the streets
but it's how you play the game
they're playing National rules not
American rules so we use it so it's blue
and red so it's like gang is a game
yeah this is James yeah there it is
New York yeah
[Music]
there's no it like it happens
oh no the thing is
there's too many of us in one place
the camera literally did not happen oh
my god oh Lord oh my God
oh my God I'm here don't be using guns
don't be that guy don't be that guy
crap
there we go
right there
it's good though
all right you gotta run in groups
but he put grenades back on
no people are running over the news
there you go
I'm spawning with your needs
what
oh damn damn turn around
he said he behind the table stop dry
Smith
turn around
[Applause]
[Laughter]
like me
to the white let's go
see what it is
there's mice in the game
uh if you got a series that's there's no
mice in your game
nice
[Music]
jump them
jump them
jumping sir
Leave With Grenades if you're getting
into the grenades they're going there
and you're just terrible oh it's not
gonna kill me
stop being scared just walk up in that
[ __ ]
what what
let me find out that Jeff Tilley
extra shield
that means that means he switch sides
huh
oh you only played on PlayStation
yikes
this is not so close this yeah it
started off tonight and then people
stopped stabbing
but I mean to be honest
people trying to use guns
it was all added for a few minutes ago
let's go
the same room
foreign
[Laughter]
we now have like over 200 speed you
can't Sprint oh I'm sorry oh what come
on oh no I'm just looking at everything
that he's doing so that's delicious
team winning squad over here
I got to go get my Ciroc
it's Saturday it's a rock day shout out
to normal Team Deathmatch wow
pina colada
okay
let's go
clamber oh Lord okay
prepare for your TV to blow up
I'm dead
[Music]
all right lemon can you give us one more
game after this
all right just for you okay
the next game would be to regular Slayer
team put an eye patch on I'm Gonna Give
You cataract whatever you want at it you
know whatever I would any smoke
anything what's this board
it's the new map built like the one new
map we've got like there's a yeah
this is the game mode
Let's Go
oh I just found the lava oh just fell in
the lava as well
oh
did it again
somehow we keep finding each other
Sinister oh this is wow
I think I think my game just go I think
my game just cracked no you broke it
it's your TV did it crash did it crash
I just died damn this to this TV
betrayed him look at that
I'm on a monitor thank you
how you hit up
jet boxes
in as well
oh my God guys I didn't even I saw
something behind me he had the iron bank
by him acrosis
with the vehicle
okay he was so fast he's an advantage
because like you're gonna be moving so
you know so slow Slugger you probably
see
I don't think so
[Laughter]
well I tried are you following me up
here yes she was
damn no [ __ ] I got him I got him
oh
this is I was trying to hit somebody
there my TV is going 400 miles an hour
keeping up man it's keeping up
but
oh I turned around
this is the murderous television
I managed to break the TVs
they move faster than my birthday
oh my gosh
a second
oh
my bad yo they just jumped me in the
Jeep
yeah this is
come on
I would have had a meltdown
you want to give us golden eye right
up in Chernobyl part 2 all over here
yo Stay Together Stay Together Stay
Together yo I haven't had sound since
our first game so I can't even hear I
need the radar
[Applause]
real shop
excuse me
at least somebody extra yo what why are
we not sticking together why are they
always together everybody else is going
to leave
since don't act differently
why are y'all playing the game
[Laughter]
sweats why are you sweating man are you
sweat bro
are you sweating bro
I don't even know what's happening
don't stop there's a dude on your back
oh
wow wow
distracting I'm not looking at that
anymore
not being able to clamber is insane oh
my God
I did that on purpose so when you're
going on these turns like you better do
that [ __ ] right
yeah
I just stay away from the middle like
all the fire stuff
won't you run for me Dutch
let's go come on
man these ghosts are killing us man
they like they can't win they can't win
sword combat jump in the vehicles
[Music]
that's right
leading that pack let's go they're in
the middle
wait the middle at the Lock
yeah
if I say turbo base nobody know what
that is
technical flexible yeah
what happened
all right last game last game
one more one more
God damn that was fast
can y'all imagine the board game modes
yeah it's gonna be crazy it's gonna come
back
I don't know about that I hope they I
hope they do
so what you may call it that um
the big ass what you would call it uh
like pubg mode
yeah I hope that happens soon man
because I really want to [ __ ] you with
everybody
I'm picking both of yours because it's
the only way to seem to get like what we
actually want they can they can do it
one Auto you don't understand sin every
time I pick something one of them
doesn't work every single time yeah I'm
looking at them on the screen on the
screen
I mean if they do the Battle Royale they
could just use the campaign map and just
drop us I mean they really have all the
assets to the game
although
all right I gotta put some Visine in my
eyes after that BS I just did I just did
it
right now
it was
oh
shout out to my TV morning pizza coming
back up
he'd be like yeah you doing too much bro
it was like about time let's go
we were all Olympic gold medalists it's
gonna be a short match
don't die
hold ah don't die yeah
have you seen this point have you seen
him play it but this might be like
knowing when he's responding and [ __ ]
oh yes
wait a minute we got no Sprint
s
yeah
he forgot to turn on yeah I put
everything back on by Sprint my bad but
it's fine
oh yeah it's fine we ain't turned around
right here this is old school
Halo this is what the oldies want let's
give it to them the oldies the oldies
heading to go
into these two feet
amen by the game man
hold up stop the match stop the man
stop it we don't have no ammo yeah
that's crazy
let me get back in that wall scavenge
for better weapons
yeah remember he said that earlier
you've got to earn your weapons all
right well earn your kills I I I gave us
plenty of ammo because the energy source
had plenty ammo
the energy sword had 36 ammo which is
plenty for an energy system trick
weapons up from the from the spawns man
take a fight pick them up Grand Theft
Auto Style
let's go
Grand Theft Auto GT I mean they they
could probably make a Grand Theft Auto
in the forest
I can see it
I got you
yeah I just finished fighting somebody
oh yeah
I saw you saw you with my third eye
oh
yeah yeah
I think he's following through
kill him
and not being able to Sprint
I got a hill man I almost died
yeah
that's right
I told I told him
this one right here
real specifically he's the fifth
tentacle this is many of them
I'm dead
it's big [ __ ] damn how do you know all
this I just know I'm enough no
Hammer eventually eventually though
all weapons
all weapons out of ammo
yeah let's let's finish this up and go
home good
let's drink good tonight guys
[Laughter]
without right it takes me so long to get
into the net that's right
hold them back knock his knees
[Applause]
right now
look at everybody else
you just jumped out the game right
everything is right with the world
hey we won how many games look at this
we don't care
right now
what happened
what I want you to do is take that rub
that in your chest
[Laughter]
it resides dead right next to your field
thanks
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
hello everyone I'm feeling fantastic
get a chance to play with friends and
this is showing people Halo's not dead
it'll just kill your TCL
everybody man Halo ain't been dead stop
it they need it
for PlayStation
well now we got that too
when they I mean hey I ain't see nobody
saying they didn't want to play
thanks for the games uh he was the yard
oh he was yard oh that's what's up yeah
yeah that's what's up oh my God
yeah
thank you [ __ ] Chinese
we'll do more of these in the future
we're gonna do them catch y'all later
today's later